y'all want to know the sounds I make
when I lift weights every time I lift
weights people think a little girls
gettin robbed and [ __ ] my life Oh what
is going on you two now you guys know I
have been on this workout grind and yes
it's been tough but now that I've
started to make working out a habit I
become melded into this gym world so
because I start to frequent this place
more often
naturally things just slowly start to
piss me off cuz we all know everybody
has gym
pet peeves and what I'm beginning to
find out is that a lot of people just
don't have basic gym etiquette and one
of those many pet peeves that need to be
said is this clean up after your [ __ ]
weights let me ask you something how are
you gonna wrap up 4,000 pounds and just
leave it on the floor out your goddamn
mind and don't say [ __ ] like well I
didn't no no no Terry Crews you knew I
was gonna use those weights right after
you I was that bad dude waiting next to
you for 15 minutes breathing hell aloud
acting like you didn't hit me huh I just
did cardio people in Africa for my big
ass breathing my teeth [ __ ] but he
didn't do it I'm alive at the cardio I
sound like a four year old elephant
trying to push out a fart hmm
listen ain't nobody got time to lift up
all your damn waste that is not a part
of my workout it's some simple [ __ ]
after you're done rack your weights you
buck miss hell you did it before just
lift it one more time in fact you soap
up you barely look like you could wipe
your own ass ho ho let me ask you this
on a serious note when you have that
much muscle how do you do it what
happens when nobody's there huh you just
sit there for hours pressure it on the
toilet angry at the world
ah you know what the sorry thing is
about all of this I know a lot of you
out there are gonna be like why don't
you just tell them to go rack their
weights then well first of all isn't it
common [ __ ] sense it's not the fact
that we haven't done it before
trust me it's just that we have to do it
every [ __ ] time and second of all
have you seen some of these prisons of
you [ __ ] they scary
true story I was on the lat pulldown
working on this machine I got up for two
seconds then suddenly this Mexican thug
came over and said info drop my machine
and I got up and I'll
[ __ ] right in the eye and saying but
this is your machine you're right I go
live I was so scared a little poop just
go over hold out my butthole like this
my surprise I told y'all awhile go I'm a
[ __ ] that butt was straight real you
get a face tattoo said it's my machine
Oh what is going on YouTube as you can
tell I've got hopefully you can that
I've been losing some weight yeah but
still going at it and slowly losing the
weight here and there and I've been
doing it a lot more healthier with just
a lot more food varieties so I can lose
these boobies but yes
don't be afraid to leave suggestions
about videos that you want me to do
because once again I'm here for you my
YouTube is for ya and once again if you
guys want to cop what I'm wearing and
cop my gear you can always get it at
home for both apparel calm and I will
catch y'all next time next week Sunday
upload an occasional Wednesday so keep
it out stay subscribe and you know
what's up but remember Fitness fam life
is always what you make it but it's up
to you to take what you deserve let's go
for Brooke I start to notice a lot more
[ __ ] that's you know me but now that
I've started to become melded into this
workout world I don't know what I'm
trying to say but now that I've made a
habit of working out I started to be
less Canela me but about bug deep deep
it wouldn't make a me